[Music]
in permit paddy news all this fall camp
[ __ ] [ __ ] her wait permit what what is
there a patty it's a new one submitted
by here in 207 Kickstarter backer
alright another white woman I like this
one is being mocked online okay hold on
after threatening to call the cops on a
little girl selling water bottles oh how
dare she that [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm talking
about that little girl
all this is on the news yesterday this
is everywhere I see this hole I didn't
see this
maybe just has a face you want to [ __ ]
kick in the I would love for Lou go sell
me some water bottles Matt walk is
getting harder and harder dude it's hot
nowadays so you want a girl on the side
of the street just handing off water
balls as you're doing your oh you're a
little [ __ ] ass box yep okay what's
going on no [ __ ] ass box are logged in
and it's been hot lately like 10 miles
that's long no it's like four Mouse
[ __ ] [ __ ] I will see you guys okay
walk for bout the day you again
[ __ ] on that [ __ ] and get it over
with
no too hard that's too hard on the
joints for miles you finish in under an
hour ease relax it's possible dude man
you got to pay me for half a mile four
months yeah I could do like what eight
minutes a mile impossible have the mile
wouldn't run in like middle school I
clocked in at 22 minutes for one mile
because they let you watch well what am
i running for but isn't that a fail
that's a F though what the [ __ ] am i
running for Bart aren't you trying to
get a PE No okay that's because you
wanted a major in yeah 22 minutes you're
trying really hard not to walk it I'm
making a point that is like literally
troll I could probably bear koala - in
under 20 minutes running is stressful it
is it is very stressful and boring not
if you have motivation that's beautiful
job have a crackhead chase you
that's not boring it's just frightening
as [ __ ] alright so this story takes
place in San Francisco and so there was
a little eight-year-old girl I was
selling water for two dollars across the
street from the AT&T park near that 18t
what a [ __ ] well she has a business
license I know the lady named Alison she
comes outside and she starts telling
like asking the little girl and your
[ __ ] do you have a permit to be selling
water around here and then why don't
white crime that's what happens oh she's
black I thought she was Mexican
automatically yeah that's true because I
always see Mexican kids selling stuff
yeah cuz like if you're around the
Hollywood Bowl oh all Mexican people
that sell drinks and they're [ __ ]
dope cuz you got a partner hot dog hot
dog oh dude check this out dude from at
the LA you know when you got the mix the
hot dogs with the bacon around it yeah
the Mexican lady had square dude what a
square hot dog no oh my god slide yeah
because she's like cuz I want that cash
what makes more sense she had been
though or she had a triangle hot dog
that no bro do you think that's why when
she was like you're done I'm like yeah
you're done the excitement was like this
is a musical like [ __ ] black sesame
buns and [ __ ] yeah I pictured like you
know they use Hawaiian breads now I'm at
dog house right and then I thought it
was a square sausage too if a sausage is
like boxy shape that means uncooked
no I was thinking like a hot dog with 90
degree angles no they got they got
squared the thing where you slide card
so you could be with card for it through
be off every time she one-up everybody
and she even had it on her little
aluminum box it said square I take card
and he just signed with the fingertip on
the iPad yeah on her iPhone oh dude
she was killing everybody's man so smart
she's like I take card yep swipe yeah
okay what did she give like a $10
minimum no hmm that see that's that's
what makes it she's so gourmet she
charged a little bit more for [ __ ] no
I was just happy dude that's a swipe I
don't think about that [ __ ] I don't you
[ __ ] how much it comes confronted permit
Patti who which isn't now what they're
calling her Butorac oh look at this
[ __ ] I don't trust [ __ ] with hips
like that man don't want to let a little
girl sell some water she call the police
on my property that [ __ ] drop was
hilarious dude where's the park across
the street so they live in the apartment
building across the street from it and
so this so apparently the mom recently
lost her job they were planning for a
trip to Disneyland
apparently the little girl wanted to
help her mom get money for the tickets
it was for Disneyland and so she started
selling water bottles outside their
apartment building and this woman Alison
lives in that apartment building she had
her window up or or it was her office or
the point is she was near there and that
she was saying that the little girl was
not like pleasantly trying to sell her
water blows that she was yelling and
screaming and non-stop saying come by my
water come by that's how the lady's
painting it and then so that's why she
wouldn't that's true I can see how that
can be annoying if
aggressive little nine-year-old selling
water get eight yes I'll get my water
sometimes they are I've ever liked pump
gas at a gas station and you see the
[ __ ] kid with the plastic tub full of
chocolates and you already know it
trying to [ __ ] sell chocolates for
some school [ __ ] it's for their Magic
Mountain trip yeah for the [ __ ] Magic
Mountain trip yeah for the kid some of
them are really aggressive give me an
example I don't remember but one time he
was like you want to buy this should I
buy that I might know much rather have a
kid try to sell me some [ __ ] than a
[ __ ] crackhead
that comes up he's like hey got money
no she's acting like [ __ ] like a hula
hoop outside she was like also to be
fair like she's bullshitting because she
could've walked out been like hey I'm
working you know my windows open just be
a little party was like where's your
permit no yeah so then she held the
numbers did she die
not four five six seven eight nine to 12
- said not to call the cops along
another extension because I don't know
the the regular phone number for the
cops I got a call 9-1-1 1-800 Popo Falah
yeah I don't even not like cuz she's
calling we don't know big reason why we
don't know yeah no so okay so what
Alison is saying is that the mom told
her well then go ahead and call the cops
once the mom told her and no we don't
have a permit and so that's when Alison
was pretending it's a college
there's why does she need to pretend
though because she wanted to scare them
well she doesn't know how to be a
regular human being and say be polite
about it like hey guys look I'm working
up there can you keep it down
Thanks exactly that's all you gotta do
you don't got to do the whole [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] oh my god they actually kind
of look
Malena that's the [ __ ] condescending
[ __ ] smile I want a [ __ ] puncher in
her [ __ ] face both of them have
oval faces - how was she screaming water
I just not that is right I just want to
know because I will I just I'm just kind
of curious like hey what if what did
that little girls a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
like she's comes up you put your [ __ ]
dry ass lives be like back it up like
yeah suck cuz look like you reach the
water cuz crack in the [ __ ] I want to
see that cuz if it is she's a little
[ __ ] back I know I know
and then we're wrong right now she's all
meat as [ __ ] sell [ __ ] water to white
people cuz she's racist as [ __ ] you
don't need water till I get my
reparations hi dude cute ass little girl
yeah you're funny no so then Alison she
has a business where she sells like
cannabis products like legal cannabis
products and and so now apparently all
these dispensaries are cutting ties with
her yeah oh oh she's so angry she smokes
weed like that neither this is not must
not be good yeah so now she's saying
like this is affecting my good my
business well you just affected that
little girl's best business that's right
that's a good point yeah so no she's
saying that she's getting death threats
and like good deeply regret and elope
she gets assassinated I don't know man
the way I see it is like if a kid sets
up a lemonade stand and it's annoying to
you I'm calling you don't go out there
and [ __ ] kick the lemonade stand down
would you want the letters in the Kenny
you squeeze lemon to look inside she
ducked down but it was like that was
like like some cartoon [ __ ] she was
that's so we got the mom recording the
cousin she's the one that tweeted the
cell and that's how I roll the caption
was so my little cousin was selling
water and didn't have a permit so this
lady decided to call the cops on an
eight-year-old hashtag permit Patti how
do you even get a permit to sell water I
mean don't they like your vendor license
yeah even the panhandlers need to have
you do I'm calling the cops and all the
homeless people not to that [ __ ] all
those fools yeah dirty [ __ ] Danielle
BAE's homeless man permit baby
no this is funny I feel like now you
know how like things escalate so much
especially with people trying to get
viral and all this yeah and then there's
like so many instances of mainly white
people calling the cops on brown people
doing nothing now I feel like it's just
gonna be growing even more I consider
brown something a little bit brown right
now Dubrow yes I'm a big club oh yes I
know people are gonna be doing it
they're probably gonna be doing it even
more because they want this I mean I
feel like this clip blew up so much
because she looks so stupid yeah she
really she really did she's like the
star of this video she looks so done
like her face just looks real stupid I
try to grab her phone and [ __ ] smack
her face with twenty times yeah if you
want to call the [ __ ] cops
and she's like selling water to it's
like how much money is she gonna make
you know what I mean it's bottled water
yeah what's her real problem her problem
is just the it was annoying to her and
she couldn't she doesn't have any
patience needs to get lazy she needs to
get the boss [ __ ] QuietComfort
headphones yeah
[Laughter]
- sponsor sponsor if I have those have
both they are fantastic here [ __ ] with
those do yeah man it's great
Kenny a scholarship
[Music]
[Music]